♪ ♪ ♪
- Une ville épargnéearar les
bombes, un calme dont on profite
comme on peut des petites
Regardez vite, vous ne voyez pae
semblent pas trop affectés. Mais
passer un peu de t d d d d d d t
déjà marqués par la guerre.
ROMAN TRUBCHANINOV,
originaire de Marioupol
installée dans les bureaux d'un
gagagaganisme à l'aide aux femm.
Une soixantaine d'Ukrainiens
une guerre qu'ils n'ont pas
cherchée, ils sont i
temporairement, désorientés,
les jours perdus à tuer
plaisir, et vie interrompue.
Dans ses valises, l'essentiel
pour survivre en quittant
Marioupol, une tante utilisée
dans les refuges sans chauffaget
au célèbre théâtre de la ville,
c'était son deuxième foyer, il a
fui Marioupol juste après
ROMAN TRUBOVOVOVOV,
originaire de Marioupol
"Personne n'est venue à notrecos
de policiers, énénénénénévoles,
personne n'est venue dans notre
nourriture ou une façon de
sortir de la ville."
- Une épreuve vécue en couple,ee
filmée. Au chaud, logés
gratuitement, ils cherchent
leur avenir. Ces j
une seule question : dans quel
'i'i'i'i'installer en attendant
que son conjoint puisse
"Il faut aller vivre dans
ces pays pour quelques semaines,
voir comment on aime ça, e
choisir. Je pense que c'est
f f f f f façon de choisir
un nouveau pays où vivre
-  Un désarroi que cette femme
comprend bien, les soldat russe
ont détruit la vie de famill
qu'elle avait lorsqu'ils ont
ennbnbnbnbnbnbass en 2014.
NATALIA VYSHEVETSKA,
- Durant les premiers mois,
on ne peut rien bâtir.
On a juste besoin de se reposere
signale pas àààààà la vie
devant, il faut parfois des
où on s'était d'abord réfugié
temporairement.
- Vous pouvez faire tous lesouon
avait pleins pour cet
pour moi-même, la famille, des
pl
l'été, mais ils n'existent plus.
- Celles-ci ont fui Irpin,
défigurées par l'artillerie
espèrent revenir un jour
peut-être.
(rires d'enfants)
Mais la famille est en sécurité,
l'ananananananand le quotidien
est pulvérisé par la guerre.
temporaire, je suis heureuse
parce que je n'aurai plus à
errer dans les rues avec
mes pensées tristes, je peux
pour l'humanité, pour moi,
pour le pays.
- Une mère inquièpour ses fille.
- J'cucucucucucucuculté
à imaginer leur avenir. La plus
moment, je pouvais l'imaginer,
mais après l'invasion russe,
je ne peux plus faire de plans.i
nous empêche de rê
cette femme.
Da
que mon fils doive allerà la gue
l'Ukraine, c'est très possible.
parce que je l'ai pas mis
au monde pour qu'il se fasse
tuer ainsi.♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪♪
- Uneueueueueueueueueux,
un drame existentiel, devant
plus qu'à s'accrocher aux petits
gestes du quotidien à espérer
que le printemps ramène le calme
Ici Yannick Dumont Baron
Radio-Canada, Ivano-Frankivs